- [Rodgers:] Welcome back to the playoffs.
We've got matchups so good, they must be scripted.
Wake up sheeple.
- Yes, I'm simply buzzing with excitement.
- [Rodgers:] In one corner, we have the Ravens.
- I have waited three long years
to get a playoff win.
And I’ll be-
Huh?
- [Belichick:] My god, it’s CJ Stroud's music.
The phenom is here.
- THAT’S MY THING. Come and get it.
- [Rodgers:] Looks like the Ravens are making a run.
- [Belichick:] A Likely story.
And it has Stroud distracted.
- [Rodgers:] And the Texans Cinderella
story comes to an end.
- [Belichick:] We also have the Chiefs again.
- Tables, ladders, and chairs.
- Oh my.
- SACRIFICE... TO THE PIT!
- [Rodgers:] Travis may be spending too much time exploring new heights.
- [Belichick:] Here come the D.K. Brothers.
- [Rodgers:] Oh, and they landed wide right!
Chiefs win!
- [Belichick:] One of these teams will win the very easy crown of AFC Champion.
- Aaron, buddy, I'm the wrestling guy.
- Sorry, Pat.
I'm like a vampire.
Once you invite me
in, I will ruin your life.
- [Rodgers:] In our co-main event, we have the Niners.
- Can you smell what the Brock is cooking?
- I can smell what the people
around you are cookin’.
- [Rodgers:] Niners win!
You know, I actually could’ve recovered from that.
- Look who's in the f--king Conference
Championship.
- I don't want to hear how f--king hard you’ve had it.
- They said I wasn't good enough for f--king Cleveland.
- Uh oh, Vita Vea!
- The run stops HERE!
- TAKE ME INSTEAD OF MY PRECIOUS JARED!
- [Belichick:] Lions win, but they're having a little too much fun for my taste.
- [Rodgers:] And the Niners will once again
attempt to lose an NFC Championship.
- [Announcer:] Passenger Josh Allen, please report to the Cancun gate
while Coach McDermott is held by airport security.
Attention Flight 58
to the Cancun section of Gridiron Heights.
We are now boarding all veterans.
All playoff loss veterans,
you are now free to board.